hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
so the PS 5 controller was revealed how
was your reaction at first I was
uncertain but after 14 tough minutes I
fell in love the futuristic look with
the quality of life improvements and a
real sense of next-generation hardware I
decided to look back through Sony's
patents in the past and previous info
about the device allowing us to spot 21
things you didn't know about the PS 5
controller let's see how many you knew
please think about subscribing for more
PS 5 breakdowns as we approach launch
date where would be the best place to
start just like any man I'm going to
start with size as we haven't been given
exact details on size I decided to line
up the ps4 Dual Shock controller with a
PS 5 dual scent controller using the
thumb sticks and face buttons as
reference for size we can instantly see
that the handles are slightly wider with
a curved effect making the product to
take note from ps4 feedback over the
years improving the levels of comfort on
the PS 5 also note that the protruding
underside of the thumb sticks is now
molded away into the body this could
make room for rear control pedals but
we'll talk about that in a little while
while we are here notice the shoulder
buttons and how they are more rounded to
fit the different grip we'll be using on
PS 5 it looks like comfort for all
gamers is the clear focus on the dual
scent controller flip the controller on
to the other side and we can see changes
in size in detail the PS 5 controller
removes the dip near the top of the
controller this will actually improve
your response time as there is a smaller
movement needed to move your finger onto
those triggers and to add to that the
dual center controller will be the first
PlayStation controller to have zero
buffer between the shoulder and trigger
buttons it's a tiny minut change that
will make a huge difference in gaming
the ease of switching between the two
and get this the potential of pressing
both at the same time that hasn't been
possible before so that could be a new
element to be implemented by game
designers next we'll take a look at
those face buttons the sacred symbols
have lost their color in a remarkable
move away from branding choice this is
not the first time though if you have a
PlayStation Portable
PSVita take a look at those buttons the
color was already removed and this is
where the PS 5 controller takes
inspiration using the same clear plastic
on the d-pad and the four face buttons
giving the design a more minimal feel in
game this also gives developers an
option to remove the button prompts
which don't suit their color scheme a
bright pink push square icon can take us
out of the immersion of a game whereas a
soft gray color will keep us in the
moment a small but great update comes on
those thumb stick grips the speckled
rubber grips have been subtly updated on
the PS 5 the center circle resembles
last generation but look at water around
the edges a star-like Triforce of bumps
these are here to give us a ditional
grip when we are in those sweat inducing
moments in many games the excuse that
your hand slipped off the controller is
no longer an issue well we'll see about
that soon we now have an extra textured
grip we can take this point further to
flipping the controller over we can see
the bottom half of the controller is
made up of a rougher plastic maybe even
rubberized to give additional grip it's
a small point but you'll be surprised
how big the industry around rubberized
controller skins is this controller
simply put is too beautiful to be
covered up now's a good time to note the
PS 5 controller just like the ps4 has an
inbuilt battery which we will need to
charge it may be difficult to see but
the port we use is a USBC pops and not
the og microUSB from last generation but
what the hell does that mean well here's
what you need to know microUSB was
brought in to do pretty much anything
it's quite ubiquitous piece of kit well
now in the world of USB 3 which by the
way is blue when you look inside the USB
hub this gives us quicker data transfer
rates of between 5 and 20 gigabits per
second so between 4 and 40 times quicker
than the previous generation and it's
damn good at recharging batteries too as
another great point to note Sony have
actually already shown us this design
choice simply look at the PS VR headsets
the same color scheme and visual layouts
are already here right in front of our
eyes we simply never paid a 10
man even the blue light is identical so
between the PS Vita and psvr
the visual language was here all along
and yet to many people the controller
looks like Astro bots or a Patil turret
of baymax or an Android from a David
cage game or an Avengers time suit or
even Borat we all see different things
that's fine talk to your psychiatrist
about it okay let's move on from visuals
for a moment and take a look at that
title Joule sense as I'm sure you all
know we've called PlayStation
controllers dual shocks for generations
this was due to two rumble motors giving
us false feedback during gaming well
fast-forward to 2020 and the Dual Shock
is no more this is the Joule sense the
main focus is now twofold with those
Rumble motors being updated and the
other aspects which Sony wants to
improve is sound so let's break them
down first of all haptic feedback and
triggers where do we start here let's go
up with the step up from Rumble due to a
coil system tension can be adjusted in
the triggers specifically the best
example of this comes from Sony who
talked about how the tension of a bowl
when pulled back will mimic a real bow
more tension more resistance to your
finger as you push the button as you
further draw the ball back that sounds
amazing
using this tech every gun we pick up
will feel different with harder to pull
triggers on heavier weapons and should a
weapon jam the haptic feedback can mimic
that sensation you likely already have
haptic feedback in your life test it on
your mobile phone right now that button
you pressed is not actually a button on
most phones the phone pretends it is it
tricks you into believing you've pushed
it turn your phone off try it for
yourself
that is not a button unless you're still
using a Nokia 3210 of course because
that's a great phone haptic feedback in
general will evolve over this generation
and likely by the time we talk about PS
6 haptic suits will exist letting us
feel every hit a character takes I just
hope you don't choose to be the bunny in
the Last of Us
the whole haptic field will run
throughout the controller allowing us to
feel sensations throughout a game for
example when using a racing game the
different textures of the road or a mud
track will be completely different
sensations this honestly this could be
brilliant
anyway that's half of Joule sense the
other half is hearing audio Sony is a
huge manufacturer and developer of audio
technologies in the ps5 generation of
gaming they plan to make this a huge
aspect of gaming you wouldn't think this
would be possible on the controller
alone and you're right most of this tech
is actually in the console itself but
there are a few pieces of impressive
tech here first the controller has a
near-field array microphone built into
the controller itself let's quickly get
our expectations completely in place
this will in no way replace plugging in
a microphone and headset and by the way
you can still use a mini jack on the
controller itself it's just a little
hard to see on the images of the Joule
sense but it is there look the inbuilt
mic is where the gimmicky tech is or it
could be the greatest tech ever quickly
will be able to speak into the
controller to let a friend know you're
busy or you need a toilet break or
something the tech uses an array of
sorts to isolate your voice and
eliminate the sounds around your room
mobile technology has used this for
quite a long time and if you have
something in your house like Amazon
Alexa you have this tech in your house
right now that's how it ends you over
other people in the room cool tech isn't
it but let's scale this back a bit I
believe the function will be used to
allow us to commentate over our video
recordings and then send them to social
media I think we are going to be part of
Sony's advertising campaign hear me out
here
remember that share button on the ps4
well now into the new generation it's so
good that other manufacturers are doing
the same to look it's here on the Xbox
well PlayStation have already changed
this design and evolved it to the next
step
this button here is the new and improved
share button named the create button
this will be the epicenter of sharing
clips uploading to social networks and
hey maybe even tick tock - hmm maybe
last gen this was all about twitch and
Facebook integration and proved to be a
huge reason why new players picked up
this console in particular hence why
Xbox is following suit on the PS 5 Sony
will allow us to widen this ability so
expect animated gifs of funny moments
uploaded almost instantly or go back to
that near-field microphone and quickly
upload a video of an epic gamer moment
complete with your own voiceover I know
I'll be doing that a lot I apologize in
advance on the PS 5 I have no doubt we
will be cogs in PlayStation social media
team for better or worse the inbuilt
microphone has also the same tech used
for voice commands once again like Siri
or Alexa and if you have the PS VR
camera you have that tech already voice
activation tech is everywhere now and
that includes the PS 5 controller have
it ready up your favorite streaming site
or select an episode of your favorite
show I personally would love to use the
microphone to instantly save my game
just shouting PS 5 saved my game just
before I go into a boss fight that could
really help a noob gamer like me another
piece of technology Sony has worked on
throughout the generation is photo mode
have you noticed almost all first party
games have this service or it is added
later on in the cycle that likelihood is
the create button on PS 5 will be where
this function is kept almost certainly
I'm starting to speculate now so we'll
probably have to wait until the reveal
of the PS 5 UI the user interface before
we can really look at this and that
reminds me do you remember the ps4 UI
reveal with some guy living in a surf
shack he was living the dream I'm gonna
keep going down the conjecture sorts of
paths now I'm thinking about it as many
things have popped up which are still to
be confirmed but they heavily suggest
something for one the PS 5 controller
and
the Joule sense I'm gonna have to get
used to saying that this bad boy has had
its light bar removed back on the ps4 it
was slap bang on the back of the pad
do you remember everyone complaining
about the glare on their screen and
thankfully Sony did dim the light but
this bar had a purpose it was so the
Sony camera could see the controller to
use it in game it was essentially for a
better experience but look at the new
controller it's gone which suggests the
dual sense will not be a functioning PSP
our controller well not at least without
an add-on or a change in tech I did a
little research and from the patents it
appears Sony are moving to a different
controller method for VR on PS 5 we
won't break that down now because we're
talking about the dual sense controller
here's another point to take note
earlier this year the ps4 back buttons
were introduced and have yet to be
confirmed for PS 5 when asked about that
Pete Hines revealed that there is indeed
a back button on the controller but as
nothing is confirmed yet this could all
be smoke and mirrors and just in case
you're thinking who the hell is Pete
Pete isn't just a random guy in the
street Pete Hines is Bethesda's vice
president he's their PR guy he is
trustworthy so we'll have to wait and
see on that one will there be no buttons
on the back will there be one button on
the back will there be room to add the
ps4 buttons on the back we shall wait
and see and finally the potential for
customization of dual sense is
staggering I'm sure by now you've seen
the hundreds of mock-ups for potential
color coordinations for this tech almost
every single one I see I want these
things could be the ultimate collectible
item there is such a potential here
what's your favorite one so far I kind
of like the white and pink one man that
looks good
so there we have it 21 things you didn't
know about the PS 5 controller aka the
Joule sense you can be honest how many
of these did you already know I'll be
lurking in the comments because that's
what I do in my spare time we'll have to
wait to see if these functions become
key selling points are just another
gimmick in the whole cycle I have high
hopes for haptic feedback and those
triggers Wow but for every piece of
brilliant tech there are rear touch pads
like on the Vita that was weird
we know your thoughts in the comments
I'm Adam from Playstation grenade it's
been a pleasure I'll see you next time
you